[Música]
y ahora vamos al repaso de las noticias
de la economía con daniela blandón nos
vemos nuevamente daniela y vamos a
empezar este repaso con el foro de davos
que termina claro que si angela después
de cuatro días de evento el canciller
alemán olaf scholz pronunció un discurso
especial en el día final del encuentro
económico más importante de líderes
mundiales que tuvo lugar en este pueblo
de los alpes suizos desde el pasado
lunes su mensaje más que económico fue
político
es contra el ghanés clave nuestro
objetivo es muy claro putin no debe
ganar esta guerra y estoy convencido de
que no la ganará él ya falló en todos
sus objetivos estratégicos es por eso
que estamos apoyando a ucrania un apoyo
estrechamente coordinado con nuestros
socios y aliados y también estamos de
acuerdo en este punto no estamos
haciendo nada que haga que la otan sea
parte del conflicto eso significaría una
confrontación directa entre armas
nucleares es más bien una cuestión de
dejarle claro a putin que no habrá una
paz impuesta ucrania no lo aceptará y
nosotros tampoco
este foro económico termina con el banco
mundial por un lado alertando sobre la
posible recesión global que puede
generar la guerra en ucrania pero
también con varias tareas pendientes
entre ellas angela el aval a un impuesto
global del 15 por ciento de las
multinacionales que quedó pospuesto por
lo menos hasta 2024
daniela vamos a cambiar de tema reino
unido- impondrá un gravamen a las
empresas de hidrocarburos como es la
noticia así es pues se trata de un
impuesto del 25 por ciento sobre las
ganancias inesperadas que hayan tenido
los productores de petróleo y gas en los
últimos meses y se suma a un paquete de
apoyo de casi 19 mil millones de dólares
para las familias afectadas por la
inflación que en este país es la más
alta en 40 años el anuncio lo hizo el
ministro británico de finanzas entre
aplausos y abucheos en el parlamento
es making externo y profes
el sector del petróleo y el gas está
obteniendo ganancias extraordinarias no
como resultado de los cambios presentes
con la solución de riesgos la innovación
o la eficiencia sino como resultado del
aumento de los precios mundiales de las
materias primas impulsado en parte por
la guerra de rusia
y por esa razón me uno al argumento de
grabar esas ganancias de manera justa y
también aguacates después de siete años
del aguacate mexicano regresa a costa
rica cómo se logró esto bueno primero
usa teoría de vivir sin aguacate o no yo
no no yo tampoco pues méxico es el mayor
productor de aguacate del mundo produce
casi 2,3 millones de toneladas al año
esto es una tercera parte de lo que
consumimos todos a nivel mundial y envía
a medio centenar de naciones entre ellas
eeuu canadá honduras entre otros pero
también en otros continentes españa
china y hasta corea del sur- compra un
aguacate mexicano pero en mayo de 2015
costa rica decidió prohibir la
importación de ese alimento
específicamente de la variedad hass al
considerar que estaba en peligro de que
al país ingresara la plaga conocida como
san blas o mancha de sol dos años
después el gobierno mexicano llevó el
asunto a instancias de la organización
mundial del comercio
en ese momento argumentó que costa rica
estaba restringiendo indebidamente el
comercio de aguacate
este año hace unas semanas el organismo
le dio la razón finalmente a méxico y
aseguró que costa rica no tenía sustento
científico para comprobar su teoría
fíjense que yo no entiendo la gente que
no le gusta el aguacate yo tampoco
entiendo que no les guste la carne el
pollo pero el aguacate no lo entiendo
esa gente no tiene corazón
los indicadores de la jornada bueno los
principales mercados bursátiles
mundiales cayeron en su mayoría este
jueves comenzando por tokio hong kong y
sed ni en asia-pacífico y con excepción
de shanghai
europa se comporta ligeramente al alza
después de que las minutas de la más
reciente reunión de la reserva federal
confirmarán que posiblemente vienen más
aumentos en las tasas de interés en los
próximos meses y también eeuu acaba de
revelar que en el primer trimestre de
2022 su economía se contrajo en
1.5 por ciento 15 por ciento y no 14
como había estimado inicialmente y su
pase para irse a descansar después de
esta madrugada daniela es la cifra del
día y señora 250 mil millones de dólares
que necesitaría sudáfrica en las
próximas tres décadas
transitar hacia una economía más
ecológica desde el actual que depende
ampliamente del carbón es que este país
es el duodécimo emisor mundial de gases
de efecto invernadero
manila gracias a ustedes por toda la
información económica nos vemos más
adelante y pues ahora llega el momento
de hablar de los deportes